[Applause]
yeah
yeah my my God those make a wish kids
can sure
scream
anyway it's Friday so you know what that
means let's welcome tonight's
guests grab a map because you're about
to get lost in his eyes Fox and Friends
Weekend co-host Pete
hson
she's so Southern she recently traded in
her iPhone for a CB radio co-host at the
bottom line on Fox buiness take it
McDow like most Philly sports fans she
wears an Eagles jersey and an ankle
monitor Fox Nation host Casey McDonald
Hosmer and finally he gets sunburned
from the refrigerator bulb Fox News
contributor Tom sh
we are in baby the show has begun but
before we get to the news let's do
this yeah gra leftovers build with it's
leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading these so if they
suck we'll break Joe Mackey's arms then
his legs and force him to play
Twister all right let's go
Brazil has reportedly seen the Advent of
nudest barber shops where no one wears
any clothes meanwhile uncircumcised
customers have been asking for just a
little off the
top pair of tickets from the performance
that President Abraham Lincoln was
watching when he was assassinated have
now been sold for
$262,000 H anyone willing to pay that
much must have a hole in their head
too too
soon it's like 150 years ago people
anyway a man was gored to death during a
running of the bulls in Spain the
funeral will be a closed casket from the
waist
[Laughter]
down come on
Tom Tyrus would have
laughed that's a great joke a white
Zimbabwean I think I said that right was
crowned as the nation's Miss Universe
representative sparking outrage in a
country that's 99% black but citizens of
all colors came together once they
realized at least she doesn't have a
penis the low bar these
days a new AI tool that's uh short for
artificial intellig Ence Pete thank you
the new AI tool has been able to
generate what Marilyn Monroe would have
looked like today in fact here's the
picture I could have done
that the National Cathedral has replaced
stained glass featuring Confederate
generals with protesters that allegedly
support the theme of racial Justice
it'll help the cathedral save on fire
insurance
yeah that's a good joke makes you think
but I would prefer you
laugh thinking is
overrated KLA Harris is incompetent
unqualified and the worst vice president
in 40 years according to voters in a
Daily Mail poll and everyone else on the
planet oh they like that
one after after years of anticipation
NASA has returned asteroid samples to
Earth in a historic first not to ruin
the surprise fellas it's a
rock it's always a
rock during the GOP debate Chris
Christie said he knows Trump is watching
because he cannot control
himself yeah this from a guy who knows a
lot about self-control
right
I'd say look in the mirror but you know
you need more than
one ohigh California that's a place has
become the first US city to recognize
the legal rights of elephants that's of
course if you don't count New York
already allowing the view to tape
here terrible people you are de deia
Blackwell a social media influencer who
uses the name meatball was charged with
eight felonies after encouraging
widespread thefts in Philadelphia her
mug shot showed tears running down her
cheeks though police say that might have
been marinara
sauce last week the Canadian Parliament
gave a standing o to a Ukrainian man who
turned out to be a former Nazi house
Speaker Anthony Roda apologized for his
lack of due diligence and hoped they
wouldn't hold it against his next guest
Mr Bol
bitler while speaking on inflation
during the debate Rona Santa spoke of a
woman who had to take food out of her
basket at the checkout to which Chris
Christie replied food did someone say
food the Wuhan Institute of Urology
warns another Corona virus outbreak is
highly likely they predict the new
strain will begin circulating as soon as
Dr fouchy invents
it yeah
yeah
yeah a British Airways pilot was fired
after bragging about a pre-flight
cocaine party I mean who does he think
he is a
Biden earlier this week in Michigan
President Biden joined striking Auto
Workers on the picket line evidently
they're the same workers who are
credited with assembling Mike
pent what's wrong with you a flock of
sheep in Greece want wandered into a
greenhouse and ate 600 lb of marijuana
plants then they wandered into a
7-Eleven and ate 900 lb of
Doritos the NYPD is deploying a new
security robot to patrol the Times
Square subway station and so far it's
working perfectly it successfully
transmitted 12 photos of the thieves who
stole it and sold it for
parts and finally during an impeachment
hearing Thursday Democrats asked
margorie Taylor green not to show
pornography again as she did in previous
testimony about hunter's criminal
Behavior disappointing former CNN legal
analyst Jeffrey tubin who was watching
at
home now to the
news fetman had his chance now it's time
to put on his pants true this fake
working class guy now asked to wear a
tie this week the US Senate unanimously
voted to restore its formal dress code
that means they've reversed the
short-lived fetman rule which had
allowed lawmakers to wear whatever they
wanted on the senate floor appeasing the
Pennsylvania Senator whose's ruined
hoodies in gym shorts for the rest of us
fedman responded to the rule reversal on
X by posting a picture of Kevin James
which is the same photo he uses to
catfish
women and a reporter snapped this photo
of him finally in a suit giving two
thumbs up so why did Schumer and his
colleagues put themselves through such
needless humil iation especially when
there's so much necessary humiliation
that they richly deserve I guess it's to
avoid admitting it was a mistake to
nominate Federman and then lie to the
American people about his condition for
the past 18 months in other words
because they're Democrats while crime
rages in our country's border dissolves
they thought the real concern was making
one goofy doofus comfortable as usual
they know priorities like Joy bear knows
proper
hygiene meanwhile liberal activist on x
which is formerly Twitter is playing the
trans card posting that it's a culture
War resolution that men must wear a coat
tie and slacks so if you are trans does
a resolution require you to dress a
certain way well I guess it depends if
they have a penis
dumb but we support this activist
wearing whatever they want as long as
the bag covers the entire
face but really dress codes are
important because once you become
lenient about that it can only get
worse looking good hey Greg got your
show notes here oh
great whoa what is that I think if the
Senate can do it why can't I I guess
it's a fair point but you need to get
that checked out not
[Applause]
again
yeah they had to blur a lot of real
estate
there
[Laughter]
so Pete uh we got all these problems
going on and it's so weird that this was
the politicians limit you're going too
far it's not when you talk about
mutilating kids or finding fighting
Foreign Wars or millions of illegal
immigrants it's about decorum that's the
clothing yeah the only thing we can get
a bipartisan bill passed on is put
clothes on yes that is abs absolutely it
by the way my office is next to yours
and I can attest that is frequently how
Greg
dresses it's not St I just give I just
give the people what they want that's
exactly and me and what they want is
less clothing more
GG uh you know uh fedman also delivered
a case of uh of Bud Light recently to
the impeachment yeah which which seems
fitting for him right yeah why is it
fitting for him you didn't expect to
follow did you I didn't
I I expected laughter and got none you
were like Mike Pence the debates laugh
now laugh now all right I'll let you
I'll let you go on this one thank you
all right you know uh denan if they care
about dorum why don't they extend this
concern to the streets where people are
getting mugged beaten up and uh forced
to listen to Pete hexus
jokes exactly um cuz they're the little
people yeah you know to too too high and
too dirty to actually go vote for them I
I'm really upset that they reverse this
because ultimately your wardrobe is the
window into your soul Greg so I'm going
to avert my eyes for the time being um I
was looking forward to Federman in tank
tops in the summer and watching the
reapplication of deodorant in the middle
of a senate session or uh in his roomy
basketball shorts you know uh cooling
down his steamy junk uh within with an
icy washcloth I'm Ser I'm serious if you
let every all of these ghouls in the
Senate dress exactly how they want to
don't you think we would know maybe know
that Menendez was up to something if his
wife dressed him he'd either be in
Versace or like a purple leather
matching warm-up outfit yeah yeah you
said Versace like that on purpose yes I
did okay good cuz I don't want to
correct you like in Show Girls yes
exactly we all remember that movie I had
a small role in that you did yes I did
yes I was the pole a small
Casey Casey Casey why did they feel it
necessary to change this is the problem
with Americo we are changing all of
these rules for like one person now
we're doing that like with with no cash
bail and everything it's like oh we have
to we have to do it for a minority of
people the criminal we change things for
one person and everybody else suffers
and then they changed it back yes the
rule is there are no rules the rule is
you you can do whatever you want you can
get away with whatever you want you look
at the riot that was just in
Philadelphia we'll talk about that but
don't and he's saying I'm a man of the
people I want to represent the people
this is how the people dress I love
comfy clothes we all love to wear sweats
and and look a little bit like maybe we
haven't showered in a few days that's
fine especially once you have kids kids
it's a thing but you no you do shower um
put your best foot for it I feel like he
had a chip on his shoulder since he beat
beloved Dr Oz I mean he's a National
Treasure he may have steered some people
wrong with the green coffee bean extract
whole thing but we still love him and I
think he just wants so badly all of
these senators all of these
Representatives they want to be
celebrities and they want to be famous
and they want to be influencers and
they're not doing their jobs MH it is
true though he should be dressing he
should be dressing for his constituents
and not for himself because you know he
should be aspiring to something greater
Tom Tom you are very well-dressed yes
you know what fox is actually they're
changing the dress code because I'm
killing it so hard with this
suit that in order to accommodate Pete
they're they're actually lowering the
dress code yes uhuh mhm um no I was
going to say that fedman does have a
chip on his shoulder it's an Intel chip
and it helps him
think Tommy uh terrible but did so funny
Greg that we we have to foot
around the fact that he's he he he is
disabled so when I bring that up the guy
shouldn't be uh in the Senate because he
is disabled and people say how dare you
say his disability makes him unable to
do his job yeah that's in the word
disabled he really is not able to do the
job um but you know I'm surprised that
they changed the law now or change this
dress code because they've let a lot of
other codes go like that one that says
um you know don't marry your brother
right and commit immigration fraud like
that one they Overlook that one ah I see
what you did there yes and uh and with
Menendez the old you know don't sew gold
bars into your
suit that one was he actually said that
that he his excuse did you see his
speech he said I'm old school like that
was his excuse for the gold bars and
yeah he's old school like Grandma and
Grandpa they always used to sld just say
you're prepping for the end of the world
and leave it at them
yeah you know it it is fun it's like
yeah I just walk around with gold in my
pocket he's like a pirate he's like a
pirate that's what he should have said
he said that uh that don't make fun of
his pirate Heritage hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else